did samsung just beat apple at the
display game well today we will find out
because we are comparing the brand new
m8 to apple studio display we're going
to cover everything from the build
quality the display quality the speakers
microphone and webcam extra features
value and much more let's go ahead and
open up this bad boy and i have to say
that when i saw the release of this
monitor i was genuinely very excited
vadim can vouch for that
just because of the price point and all
the features that it has and that you
can use it not only as a smart tv
but other features to make it more like
a computer at that low price point now
of course the packaging does not match
up to apple's studio display which is
overkill but super super nice
but let's go ahead and see what we get
inside i gotta say that i definitely
like this herringbone pattern it's a lot
better than just flat plastic like on my
lg ultra fine that shows fingerprints
and this one doesn't now weight not too
heavy but the panel is quite large let's
go ahead and grab our stand here this
reminds me of the pro display xdr stand
but a lot lighter and not a thousand
dollars and check this out it is height
adjustable without having to spend
another 400 bucks which is nice now even
though this is plastic it actually has a
good amount of weight to it because of
the mechanism inside and the base is
actually completely metal for extra
stability now we do have to put this
together
and we do have one screw that we have to
tighten down now i did actually buy one
of these right at launch but then
samsung reached out and they wanted to
get us one earlier and i was like of
course i want to cover it and i want to
replace my monitor at home with one of
these so this is a sample from them
let's go ahead and pop in the stand you
do not need a screw or anything bam it
is popped in and we are all set up all
right guys look at this beast right here
32 inches compared to 27 that's a big
difference and i gotta say that i am
very impressed with this stand for a
built-in stand for a fairly inexpensive
monitor with compared to the features it
is actually really nice way better than
the 1300
lg 5k that thing is terrible and wobbles
like crazy now as i mentioned the
samsung is height adjustable out of the
box you can lower it or you can go all
the way up this high so that is nice
without having to spend that extra 400
and to me um the studio display is about
one to two inches too short but not
enough to get me to spend that money now
apple tries to get around this by
offering a ton of tilt adjustability to
aim it up at your face
the m8 can't go as far back as you guys
could see because then it would be
hitting that stand neither of these can
go vertical but the m8 does allow you to
adjust the level but personally i'd
rather have it be static and more solid
now as far as build quality is samsung
is better than i expected but it does
not even come close to apple's
all-aluminum design feels way more
premium way more solid the whole stand
is one piece very very sturdy it looks
gorgeous and the whole front is all
glass instead of being plastic for the
display now as far as connectivity the
studio display uses thunderbolt 4
and then it also gives you 96 watts of
charging plus three usb ports that run
at full 10 gigabit per second speeds
which is really nice now the m8 uses usb
type c and it only gives you 65 watts of
power which is enough for most but it
won't really max out your laptop if you
have a 16 inch and then you get a 5
gigabit per second usb c port and then
you also get a mini hdmi now you do get
both cables and the mini cable has a
standard hdmi on the other end and i do
like how all the ports are hidden behind
here that way you don't see anything
coming out from the side and then going
back through your little cutout so it
makes it a lot cleaner now the m8 is
quite a bit thinner than apple studio
display but that is because it has an
external power brick this massive two
stage system
that is just so bulky now of course it's
gonna sit on your floor probably next to
the outlet but apple's display has all
of that built in and lastly before we
turn these on the samsung also comes
with this really small remote that
charges with usb type-c that gives you
your netflix disney prime smart options
all of that because this is technically
a tv as well
and this is the coolest part you get
this webcam that magnetically attaches
to the back of the monitor
bam it is attached and you have a webcam
and if you don't need it you take it off
now with that it also has this little
metal magnetic cover so if you want to
keep it attached but you want privacy
literally just pops on to block the
webcam or you can remove it pop it on
the back so you don't lose that cover i
wish apple did something like this
because this is what allows the m8 to
have such thin bezels all around while
still having a 1080p webcam
it is just such a cool little feature
but of course if apple did that they
would charge you probably a couple
hundred bucks for the webcam separately
now let's go ahead and spin these around
and turn them on and start comparing the
speakers the webcams and the display
quality the setup was pretty easy on the
samsung you just use your smartphone to
get everything ready and now we have it
set up here and it's pretty much looking
just like a tv you have different apps
that you can download you have free tv
streaming now we can go ahead and switch
over to
workspace and this is really really cool
you can actually connect to a windows pc
to a mac or samsung dex even wirelessly
and be able to use those devices on this
display even if they're not in the same
room you can also have smart apps like
microsoft 365 services
you can connect a keyboard mouse either
wired or by bluetooth so this is
something that i would love in the
studio display now let's just go ahead
and switch over to a monitor now i was a
bit worried how it would connect to our
mac and if i'd have to get a windows pc
but we're having no issues it shows up
and it's actually labeled as a samsung
in our display settings the size is
accurate and then if we go to the sound
settings the speakers also show up
properly through the display port and
not only that the detachable webcam also
shows up perfectly without having to
install anything and that is awesome now
as you guys could see the bezels are
extremely slim and the display is much
larger now we're going to cover all the
display differences in just a sec but
first let's compare those speakers and
the webcam
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys wow you heard it for
yourselves now the samsung it does get
loud it actually probably gets a little
louder than the studio display but the
quality of the sound and the depth and
the bass in the clarity
it is not there now we have four
speakers here they are rear facing which
means that it's not bouncing off of
anything in this scenario where the mac
is bouncing off the table but even if
you added that you're not gonna get any
of that richness in that base so it is
just no competition and i think if you
are an adult you're gonna be watching
movies on this display airplane uh you
are gonna need to add at least a
subwoofer or some other speakers or a
sound bar or something to actually make
it a good tv now i wanted to make sure
that it's not just the connection from
the imac so i actually airplayed to it
which you can do it's super sweet but
the sound quality stayed the same and
that is with the amplified setting
inside of the settings which does make
it sound better than the standard now as
far as webcams and microphones a lot of
people have been very critical about the
webcam that's in the studio display it
is 1080p but as you guys can see there's
a lot of noise it's not very contrast
it's more flat now it is a ultrawide
camera that is currently being cropped
in order to give you this normal view
but then if you're using software that
supports it for conferencing it will
automatically adjust and that is why the
quality doesn't look that good when it
is a 1080p and here is the webcam in the
microphone quality of samsung's m8 it's
also a 1080p camera but it looks quite
large on there and i can see that there
is very little noise and there's a ton
of contrast honestly too much now this
could also crop in and zoom out but i
don't really know what it's doing
currently because i'm not connected to
zoom or another application that
supports it but you guys take a look at
this side by side right here and let me
know which one looks better to you and
also comment which one sounded better in
terms of microphone now i know you guys
heard that weird awful staticky ticking
sound with the m8 microphone that is
actually being picked up by it and i
looked up at somebody else's review the
audio recording they also had that issue
hopefully that is something that is not
a hardware issue but just software that
needs to be fixed now getting into
display quality the first thing i want
to talk about is just that size
difference in scaling the 32 inch 4k
display is being ran natively and it
actually is big enough that if you have
decent eyes you can use it without any
scaling for the sharpest results and you
actually get a lot of screen real estate
whereas the studio display it uses
two-time scaling perfectly for 5k from
1440p now as far as sharpness there is
no comparison the studio display has 218
ppi so text looks nice and crisp sharp
this is what i've been used to the last
six years since the lg 5k came out and
even the imac before that now with the
m8 you have a 4k display up to 32 inches
that's a large screen so when you look
at it if you're used to a nice high
resolution display higher than 4k it
does look soft now if you're somebody
that comes from a 1080p screen let's say
24 inch that is only 92 ppi
this thing is 140 so not only get a
larger screen it will actually get
sharper as well so overall it's not bad
it does work well but it's not the
luxury detail and sharpness of an imac
or you know studio display now as far as
display brightness it's actually not as
big of a deal as i expected we have 600
bits compared to 400 and if you're
straight on both are plenty bright but
where the samsung falls apart is if
you're viewing off axis
you have a lot of color shift you'll
have a lot of brightness shift contrast
loss and that is because it is actually
a va panel not an ips panel with that
there's also some uniformity issues
where the corners are darker almost like
a vignette filter on a photo whereas the
studio display doesn't have that issue
at all now on the flip side the contrast
when you're sitting straight on looks
amazing because of that v8 panel the
studio display already has the best lcd
display that apple has put out but this
panel has really nice contrast the
brightness is bright enough for the
content it pops uh and as far as
reflectivity you do get a little bit
more reflections but it's a matte
display so it's dispersed compared to
apple which has a full glass panel with
really nice coatings so you do get extra
sharpness and detail on um the studio
display
but the samsung actually performs better
than we expected now as far as color
accuracy the m8 does actually output 99
srgb so if you want to use it for photo
editing video editing you can you just
want to make sure that you get a color
calibrator now the studio display is
calibrated out of the box and it can
actually do a hundred percent of dci p3
so it's excellent for people working
with video if you care about color
accuracy it's going to do a killer job
definitely a better job
now overall we've done all this
comparisons these are completely
different price ranges we have 700 bucks
with a whole smart tv and remote pc
access and the webcam all of that
compared to
1600 i mean more than twice the price so
it really comes down to what you're
looking for if you want the best of the
best displays where you care about
luxury you care about the materials you
care about having that extra brightness
and sharpness i mean this new studio
display is amazing while the m8 the
thing that stands out to me is that one
it looks good better than most uh
windows monitors that are created for
windows systems it works with macs
perfectly has airplay you can stream you
can mirror you can remote access you can
go ahead and open up any of these apps
it is just very very versatile you can
play run alexa on there so you don't
need an echo in your room if you want
something to put in your room that you
can not only use as a monitor but you
can just sit from your bed or from a
couch and be able to watch movies uh you
want to be able just use it as an
all-around tv display plus more it is a
killer system for that price of 700
bucks just don't expect you know really
good sharp details from it like the 5k
or super high quality as far as the
build you get kind of what you pay for
and for that 700 bucks it offers a ton
of value personally we're gonna set this
up at home for my kids and i'll continue
using my 6k xdr for daily use let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section below do you like this
offering from samsung do you guys like
the look click above to subscribe to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there this max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]